[Music]
i wanted to show them something that
wasn't an illusion
something that was real
something that we could
see and touch
creation
is an act of sheer will
life
will find a way
we can't keep her here forever
they find her we're never gonna see her
again we gotta protect her that's our
job
humans and dinosaurs can't coexist
[Music]
we created an ecological disaster
ellie sadler
alan grant
you didn't come out all this way just to
catch up now did you you coming or what
[Music]
we're racing toward the extinction of
our species
we not only lack dominion over nature
[Music]
we're subordinate to it
[Music]
come back i always come back
that's another plane right
not exactly
don't move
bigger why do they always have to go
bigger
[Music]
who are you under there
what are you hiding
my son dreamt of a better world that's
why he saved me
you can go to any timeline and the
universe
might fight to save this one
what could be greater than a king
a hero
i just got goosebumps
[Music]
if we don't stand up no one will
come with us
it's a glorious world out there
waiting for you
are you in
a year of work for a four-minute flight
isn't that something we're all ready if
you are sir well let's go find out if
this
we got a breach in the perimeter
thank you
[Music]
i was like your mission law
after a full year of being marooned on
this planet
our first test flight is a go
[Music]
but get everyone home good luck
captaining
roger that
[Applause]
[Music]
i am socks your personal companion robot
we're being pursued by a
just a massive robot
[Music]
that was utterly terrifying and i regret
having joined you
right here
[Music]
i can provide sleep sounds if you like i
have several options summer night ocean
paradise whale calls no no white noise
is fine very well good night socks good
night buzz
every night
i dream the same dream
then
the nightmare begins
i did what i had to do
to protect our world
you cannot control everything strange
you open the doorway between universes
and we don't know who or what will walk
through it
[Music]
what do you know about the multiverse
this had his theories
he believed it was dangerous
he was right
i'm sorry stephen
your desecration of reality
will not go unpunished
we should tell him the truth
[Music]
things just got out of hand
[Music]
you break the rules look up
become a
hero i do it i become the enemy
[Music]
that doesn't seem fair
right
[Music]
there are some would make me out to be
the villain
of this here story
[Music]
are you born with destiny
or does it just come
knocking at your door
as a young singer from memphis tennessee
give him a warm hayride welcome
[Music]
mr elvis presley
get a haircut buttercup
in that moment
i watched that skinny boy transform
into a superhero
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he was my destiny
i wish to promote you mr presley
are you ready to fly i'm ready ready to
fly
tomorrow all of america will be talking
about
they might put me in jail for walking
across the street but you're a famous
white boy
[Music]
but it has nothing to do with us it has
everything to do with us
[Music]
and nobody's gonna remember me
[Music]
[Applause]
i just gotta be making the most of this
thing while i can
this can all be over the flesh
[Music]
we are the same you and i
we are two odd lonely children reaching
for eternity
[Music]
the greatest show on earth
elvis has left the building
what is this taken am i talking
alan i'm here to save you
the key to finding the lost treasure
after them i am driving oh
just pick it up
getting you out of here why are you so
handsome my dad was the weatherman the
lost city march 25th
sonic the hedgehog
you're no match for me
[Music]
[Music]
work smarter not harder
that wasn't too bad
sonic the hedgehog 2 april 8th
did you know that the very first
assembly of photographs to create a
motion picture was a two second clip of
a black man on a horse and that man is
my
great great grandfather great there's
another great grandfather
[Music]
but that's why back at the haywood ranch
as the only black owned horse trainers
in hollywood we like to say since the
moment pictures could move
yeah skin it again
[Music]
[Music]
uh
was a bad miracle
[Applause]
we got word for that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
daddy what's going on sweetie
something feels weird
something's changing you remember the
tools we typed right
pencil
desk paper shoes you're weird everything
okay charlie it happened again what
happened to that thing if you ever start
to lose control what do you do it didn't
work
she's not a robot and she's a little
girl
with little girls emotions which are
wildly unpredictable
charlie she just has to shove it down
and keep it hidden
our responsibility is getting her ready
our responsibility is to protect her
charlie
if they catch her they're gonna put her
in a cage charlie
who catches me
something's happened i need it handled
with discretion
and i need her back alive holy [ __ ]
do you know what it means to be on the
run bad men are after us really bad i
hate living like this
you're special charlie i'm
i want to help her you want to use her
charlie don't be stupid
do you feel that
let her go it's gonna get a lot worse
mommy tell me now
it's the first of her kind
a real life
superhero
you need to understand how to use it
it can't be a reaction it's gonna be a
decision
that's the only way that you control it
she's becoming a young woman i'm not
going to jail and someday soon
she may be capable of a nuclear
explosion
on your knees simply with the force of
her mind
who will go in
trust me charlie
you don't have to be afraid
please i can help you liar liar pants on
fire
i don't want to hurt anyone
but it feels kind of good
[Applause]
[Music]
real hollywood story
chippendale rescue rangers the show that
defined the generation and turned two
unknown chipmunks into international
superstars
but his success took chip and dale to
new heights to many more seasons of the
rescue rangers we were living the dream
dancing the roger rabbit with roger
rabbits
it could all come crashing down
torn by vanity you look different hey
it's no secret i had the cgi surgery
done
consumed by temptation my love of cheese
got the best of me i just love it so
much more please
more please
is it possible that two living legends
are destined to reunite
i'm thinking reboot nobody wants a
reboot
it's a rescue ranger you need a disguise
or something grab the first thing you
can
uh
what
[Music]
[Music]
rescue rangers 2.0
[Music]
this place looks weird remember that
animation style where everything looked
real but nothing looked right who are
you
are you talking to us obviously but it
looks like you're talking to that window
it actually looks like i'm looking right
at you okay look at my eyes looking
right at your eyes
[Music]
blackbeard captain kidd
the gentleman pirate well the first two
are like very very talented pirates
but the last one is the scariest of them
all instead of killing with weapons he
kills with
kindness
oh right so you're the gentleman pirate
then well sussed
the rumor is you up ended your entire
comfortable life
become a pirate
i got bad news for you genital pirate
pirating is not for everyone
it's a really dangerous lifestyle
lovely one on blackbeard
huge fan sir huge
we're gonna go on up there and
we're gonna cause some havoc how violent
do you expect us to get
the duster
why'd you take it
i'm just looting this library when i'm
replacing all the books uploaded with
ones i've already read
you know how hard is to find someone
doing something original out here
do these outfits maybe feel like an
error in judgment it's a power move make
people feel underdressed and suddenly
you're the one in charge
you're lunatic and i like it
let's have fun with it
[Applause]
come on
give a man a warning that was your
warning
a lot of the guys are sweethearts deep
down
they're just dealing with a fair amount
of trauma
permission to blow them to hell captain
and we're quite certain that pirates
hard to say
one appears to be a heavy set woman in a
silk dressing gown everybody hide
a gentleman never arrives empty-handed
amid tapa
toughest means little plates
yeah you know about tapas
[Music]
what's a better soldier you're my dad be
careful
come on let's go did you actually see my
dad's life yes
we looked after each other
brothers
yeah kind of like brothers
james the cleaning house
you're leaving the army with an
honorable discharge but you're losing
your pension and health care
we gave them our minds our bodies and
our spirit they'd shoot us up and spit
us out
i just want to check in with y'all on
your past due payment message deleted
what you did in the uniform sledgehammer
[ __ ]
our thing scalpel work
we operate a deep black og offshoot with
direct presidential authority
bank some decent cash put a down payment
on the house
that's not dangerous now i know you're
lying maybe i need to take care of my
family so what do you say you're down
for the cause yeah
study pathogenic influenza viruses in
humans
we all know what one motivated radical
can do
so let's cowboy up get it done and get
home to our families you don't
understand what you're doing i'm trying
to save lives
this is only about money
what do we do mike
i've got an extraction team brown bmw x1
comply i'll do that when you confirm who
you're working for you work for me
you gotta trust me i am trying to help
you oh we're working for the president
corporation
get in the car
they train us to run their errands
kill their enemies and kill each other
it's easy to kill but it's much harder
to survive
need to get back home
home's in memory
he's gonna come after you with
everything he's got
i'm going home
[Music]
[Music]
bye
[Music]
[Music]
what are you doing here
[Music]
why are you doing that
[Music]
so
[Music]
three
two
one
[Music]
the car smells really weird
there's a bomb under your seat
thank you for the information
don't even think about hanging up on me
so who are you what do you want get
together 3.4 million in cash some guy
just told me he's put a bomb in my car i
got the call too where are you now it's
a little like stepping on a landmine
anyone gets out it explodes you contact
anyone it explodes piss me off it
explodes get out we're dead listen just
hang in there just in case all right
attention all units
private banking center manager who
manages vips can't get a hold of 3.4
million i'm only calling because uh it's
about a 10 return on investment i handed
you a deal like that and you couldn't
close it did you forget i'm holding the
detonator
step out of the
vehicle
materials for homemade homes were found
right inside the suspect's home i
already told you not to hang up on me
get out of there
if you'll let me go i'll detonate the
bumpers
it's nice to finally meet you
always doing your best
that's always been your problem
if you just lived an ordinary life none
of this would have happened
the women in our parents generation
they were more into femininity you know
what i mean
because i think you would just look
great in a dress
but i mean if you were pretty much done
actually thank you if it's cool i'm just
going to snag these leftovers
i don't know how you do it
hating people
no no
you do not need a man okay
so don't play the games just be you
straight out the gate
do you live around here
because i live on aisle six
that was terrible
it was kind of terrible
what's his instagram i want to stalk a
little bit you just have one say what
yeah oh no see that's
that's shady let's play a game tell me
something you don't want me to know i
hate this okay
for all our hopes of finding happiness
through someone else yeah
girl you're all dygmatized and i haven't
even seen this dude
what's going on i'm gonna tell you but
you're gonna freak out
no this isn't happening
yeah it's happening
no games not what you wanted
it's about giving
giving yourself over to somebody
[Music]
becoming one forever
that's love
it's a straight girl's fantasy come true
right
[Music]
i figured it out yeah seven times a
charm
don't be an actor oh god
you don't belong with those la folks
they're a bunch of fascist hippies
what brings you here and i figured no
better place to be discovered in the
supermarket hey did i see you on a
television series you do movies you
don't work in any team industry at all
no man
you'll know you're fussing with this
truck i'm a son i'm just boring it i
reckon it's a few months worth of
cleanups on aisle four to pay off a dui
income
what can i get for you miss i got beef i
can see that
hey
hey
let's not waste either of our time i'm a
catholic why ain't that what confessions
were you can't date someone who wasn't
baptized
i thought you was gonna say hispanic
where's the water i'll do it now i know
i'm not what you used to
but not what you deserve either life's
gonna give you a gut full of reasons to
be angry
you only need one to be grateful
[Music]
i think god saw something you worth
saving
but it's up to you to decide what you've
got to offer
it's the place you told me you believed
in me i thought it makes sense being
back here to do this
[Music]
your son is about to make a huge mistake
i'm gonna be a priest
for halloween
huh i'm praying for you bill don't you
dare you're violating my right there's a
man
going around taking names we've all been
wrong and we've all done some wrong but
he came to forgive us everybody won't be
treated all the same there's no easy way
to deliver this news you have a
progressive muscle disorder the muscles
weaken until he ceases to function is
there anything it doesn't mess with yeah
erectile function
i'm trying to be a priest pal the wise
men will bow down before the throne i
don't know
why
when at his feet they'll cast their
golden crown men don't lose when he gets
knocked down
the money won't get up
our baby
there is concern amongst the diocese
that your infirmity will render you
unable to be a priest listen to the
words long written down what you guys
get one phone call a week in here who
you gonna call huh when no one else
gives a [ __ ] what you got to say god
does when the man comes around he ain't
giving up on you don't you dare go
giving up on yourself hear the trumpets
here the pipers
[Music]
i gotta get your ass to church on time
who are you here to visit sir father
still
you and everybody else
we shouldn't pray for an easy life
but the strength to endure a difficult
one
[Music]
well you can't say i never gave you
nothing yeah i skipped over thanking you
went straight to the source
exclusively in movie theaters
[Music]
oh no it's a code red coachman okay
we're late let's roll let's go
i'm zoey dj let's go
up and adam and this is paul morning
jake
we turned our two families into one all
right rise and shine
wake up ella or this video goes on your
instagram in three two dad no touch me
lose a finger good morning to you too
[Music]
luna strong choice suggestion take off
one thing solid advice
dryer's broke again how did you get down
here so fast laundry shoes let's go
let's go let's go
we're not a call too but we're weird
we're one of a kind all the way thank
you thank you very much thank you thank
you thanks
i really feel like there were a few
extra children in there i didn't
recognize some of them
where are the bakers
ten kids and no nanny wait you have ten
kids shockingly i enjoy being with my
kids
i do too you too yeah i do too
you guys are funny no you can't
go to your room dance with us because
we're so irresistibly adorable you're
not even doing it right you have to clap
the back of the hands and then throw
you're embarrassing the family go to
your room oh lord get me straight
it's important to show the kids that
we're united who invited the jackson
nine if y'all looking for disneyland you
made a wrong turn
[Music]
family has each other's back oh my god
everyone's looking at us
[Applause]
i know i'm thanks for being so average
and relatable paul with average looks
and ordinary body wow
what are you guys playing drag race fun
i love rupaul
it's not what it seems so you guys
weren't having a fast and furious style
race for money whoa i just realized
we're not smarter than you
foo fighters you gotta get me a record
it's our tenth album we gotta break the
mold on this one what's up
let's go somewhere we've never been
[Applause]
this place is amazing
do you guys get this overwhelming sense
of death
doesn't really seem like the right fit
whoa
that was weird the sound of this house
is the sound of album 10.
all right all right you guys amps living
room let me apologize in advance for all
the rock we're about to make
got a couple of ideas i've been working
on i'll lay them on you
[Music]
dude
it's called everlong and you wrote it
about 20 years ago
how you feeling everything okay ever
since we moved into this house
my mind is flooded
we all have writer's block this is not
just a creepy rock and roll house
it allows spiritual entities to cross
into our world
oh my god
dude has got one flew over the cuckoo's
nest crazy
it's this place man
let's finish the track can we just wait
dude
found a new musical note help yes i did
any chefs in the group i'm pretty handy
on the grill
yeah you like your meat charred and dry
he does make a killer barbecue
what do we do we go save his ass
[Music]
almost done yeah it's killer
you go man finish the song
[Music]
we're still trying to figure out what
happened
[Music]
when did you last hear from her
[Music]
she left to bring her to school
is everything okay
i she gone missing before
not in a long time
mom
i heard about your mom is she all right
it doesn't feel right
i think we should go away just two of us
think you should take it easy at the
moment mom
where did you go
i can't tell you
not yet
are you awake
what's wrong with you
there's things i need to tell you
it's not your mother up there if we
don't do something we'll never get her
back
and then they'll try to take you
dance with me sure
mom stop
how is your mom
[Applause]
[Music]
the germans must be coming he can smell
them
who the red ghost
they say he sent 100 crowds to meet
their maker
who has seen the lads ghost
maybe he's immortal
and get ready for battle
sorry
try
grenade
[Music]
now just a little closer
it's our chance maybe your only hope
just tell us your name
hello
come
when i first saw you
i saw love
looks like we made
they'll never make it
[Music]
[Applause]
lulu is that you do you give hugs now
really lulu was the best you've never
had a lulu
no we don't we don't exactly hug
dog you're definitely not the girl i
thought i'd be in the tub with but i'll
take what i can get at this point i
guess
see it in a special sneak preview
valentine's day in theaters everywhere
february 18th don't worry the dog
doesn't die for the pg-13
why are you the only man who wants to
stay with me
i don't know
thank you too
i do
you love me
of course
you're not born
no
there's something wrong with me
there's something wrong with me too
have you told them lady grantham she's
told us nothing do
sit down i've come into possession of a
villa in the south of france what villa
start at the beginning
years ago before you were born i met a
man
they spent a few days together and he
gives her a house you never thought to
turn it down do i look as if i'd turn
down a villa in the south of france
a telephone call for you my lord mr
barber is a producer and director he
wants to make a film at downtown a
moving picture a downtrend
i think it's a horrible idea actresses
plastered in makeup and actors just
plastered there is something about it
like a wild animal ready to spring ready
to spring on you you mean
action
cards cut sorry
the modern world comes to downtown
why do you think he gave you the villa
that is where the mystery resides then
go off to the riviera and with any luck
we'd miss the whole of mary's frightful
film
i do hope that was a prop
you steer ahead
you're the captain now
they better be warned
the british are coming
welcome to the villa of the doves it's a
beautiful place how happy you must be oh
my goodness who is she the lady grantham
i first went to work for granny
why did you invite us here
[Music]
it doesn't look good for papyrus without
the need to keep it a secret
there's trouble in paradise you don't
need me to tell you that marriage is a
novel full of plot twists along the way
women like us fall into two categories
dragons and fools you must make sure
they think of you as a dragon
with that i will say good night and
leave you to discuss my mysterious past
it seems the public only want films that
talk i should have thought the best
thing about films is that you can't hear
them be even better if you couldn't see
them either
[Music]